here we go face first into hockey before
the year 2020
an nhl team playing one period and then
waiting eight hours before playing the
second period at 9pm pacific time
will be considered extreme adversity but
in a pandemic this was just a fun day at
a resort with
extra time to think about hockey for the
golden knights it felt like
a season of its own nine hours between
goals the puck dropped at high noon
and then the second period puck dropped
with a high of 22 degrees
the golden knights also found their
toughest adversary in the west for the
remainder of the season
it's the avalanche they're just faster
and just as skilled as knights
colorado won 3-2 for their second
straight win over vegas and
the drama builds with many more matchups
on the horizon
it was an unbelievable experience i was
a little nervous honestly i know the
outdoor game is watched by a lot of
people
uh we got a lot of fans back home in
vegas and i got a lot of people watching
back home in upstate new york and uh it
was a little nerve-wracking at first but
it was
it was exciting too to fly over and uh
we honored some of the um
military and first responders and uh
they were it was great to see them come
out uh
in the local tahoe area um but you know
it was a lot of fun it was uh we saw ya
on the lake with some people cheering
and i think they were vegas fans too
the avalanche wrote the book on how to
take a hockey town by storm in the first
season after they relocated from quebec
to denver
they won the stanley cup vegas also
known for starting fast now must figure
out how to keep colorado from
overtaking them in the west vegas as we
mentioned lost their last two by a score
of three to two to colorado
the avalanche attack with versatility at
so much speed
and they may have the only goaltender in
the west as sturdy and reliable as
marc-andre fleury right now
the golden knights say while they love
their time in tahoe they need to win
more than anything
you know i'll remember this experience
you know anytime you have an opportunity
to
to play in an outdoor game it's a it's
pretty special and
you know we had a good practice
yesterday are able to take in uh
taking the sights a little bit obviously
in warm-ups and things like that
but as for the game you know obviously
it's uh it's pretty disappointing these
are some big points and
um you know certainly too that we wish
we would have gotten
oh but you can't beat the anticipation
ambiance for a hockey fan it was so
unique to
see the rink built on the edge of lake
tahoe the knights entering the ice with
those retro red
throwback jerseys looking sharp but
remember no fans allowed but that didn't
stop some fans from trying to catch a
glimpse
of the action about 25 boats watching
the edge
of the lake to see if they could catch
some of the historic game
and the biggest boat was full of the
most rabid fan base a boat full of
knights fans who paid
100 bucks each to watch from about 300
yards away
they came they saw and they don't regret
it here we go
ryan reeves i don't know you can't see
the back but i have the ryan reeves
jersey he came out
last year and did a learned escape with
my boys it was lovely for a minute
and evidently they had some ice issues
so back at it tonight
honestly we just wanted to get close and
it was a good time
so fun you can't beat lake tahoe i wish
the boat could have gotten a little
closer but it was spectacular
it'd be nice to see it i think it was a
beautiful backdrop oh it was amazing
what a cool experience i'm sorry the ice
didn't hold up but yeah
you know that thing's pretty powerful
great way to view the game that's what i
was going to say was it kind of cold
it's been on the lake
yes you can't be in a better scenery
than this and
with a better group of people people
don't realize in lake tahoe you know we
have about 95
of sunny days so yeah the ice probably
melted